vor fast einem Jahr russische
Supermarktregale Lehren sich große
Ketten verlassen das Land das Ziel China
die russische Wirtschaft deutlich
Schwächen an der Wirksamkeit gab es
keinen Zweifel
wir sehen die Sanktionen wirken
Russlands Wirtschaft wankt die Börse ist
weitgehend geschlossen die Währung ist
abgestürztes fehlen die Wiesen
ausländische Unternehmen verlassen zu
Hunderten das Land
doch das ist jetzt der Anfang doch das
war ein Trugschluss andere Marken füllen
schnell die Regale die Währung
stabilisiert sich überraschend zwar
verlassen über 1.000 Unternehmen
Russland aber viele machen dennoch
Geschäfte die jell-universität Liste
Firmen auf die trotz des Krieges weiter
handelt treiben sie nennen sie Liste der
Schande sie ist beschämend blank und der
Wirtschaftsminister muss eine große
sanktionslücke eingestehen es gibt
deutliche Umgehungen der Sanktionen und
es gibt auch deutlicher Umgebung aus
Deutschland heraus der Sanktion ich will
an dieser Stelle einmal politisch sagen
das ist kein Kavaliersdelikt so liefert
die EU beispielsweise Handys oder
Kühlschränke zum Beispiel an Armenien
das Land verkauft diese dann an Russland
weiter allein das kleine Land Armenien
importierte 166 Prozent mehr als im Jahr
vor dem Krieg der Verdacht über Umwege
bekommt Putin militärisch wichtige Güter
erst im dezember besuchte Putin den
armenischen Präsidenten erst am
Donnerstag besuchte der armenische
Präsident den deutschen Bundeskanzler
dem bleibt nicht viel mehr als ein
Appell können wir sicher sein dass nicht
im ökonomischen Bereich umso Sanktionen
umgangen werden und das ist natürlich
etwas was wir als Anforderung schon
haben und wo wir auch die Hoffnung haben
dass das
beachtet wird was wir an Regeln haben
die EU Regeln wirken zuweilen hilflos
Marktwirtschaft lässt sich schwer
aushebeln so verkauft Russland zum
Beispiel Rohöl nach Indien nur günstiger
als vor dem Krieg in ihr macht daraus
diese den EU-Bürger tanken bei den
Ölsanktionen wird man nicht viel machen
können man wird nie verhindern können
das Russland
bei über 200 Ländern in der Welt
irgendwelche Abnehmer findet bei Gase
ist vielleicht ein bisschen schwieriger
weil man eben dort andere
Transportmöglichkeiten hat aber das ist
Öl irgendwo anders verkauft wird oder
die Kohle waren das verkauft wird lässt
sich praktisch nicht verhindern
wobei die Einnahmen deutlich geringer
sein dürften dennoch prognostiziert der
IWF Russland für dieses Jahr sogar ein
leichtes Wachstum mehr als für
Deutschland manche fragen sich leidet
Deutschland gar mehr als Russland was
folgt daraus die Opposition und eins das
ist ein Problem aber wir müssen hier nun
ganz einfach auch zu unseren Werten
stehen zu unseren Zusagen stehen wir
müssen dazu stehen dass wir der Ukraine
nach allen Kräften die wir haben auch
helfen und wir verhängen Sanktionen
jetzt schon in der zehnten Runde und das
sind die Mittel die uns zur Wahl stehen
und diese Mittel die müssen wir auch
ohne jede Einschränkung anwenden die
Sanktionspolitik wie wir sie
aktualisieren schadet der eigenen
Bevölkerung mehr als der russischen wir
Schaden unserer Wirtschaft wir schauen
unseren Unternehmen und die Bevölkerung
in Deutschland leidet weil sie ihre hohe
Energiekosten zahlen muss
Wissenschaftler dagegen fordern einen
langen Atem Sanktion des Instrument
wirken primär in der langen Frist diese
Wirkung wird da sein Russland wird
technologisch rückständ iger es werden
weniger und weniger moderne
Produktionsstätten da sein ich glaube
diejenigen die gehofft haben dass man
mit Sanktionen den Krieg sehr schnell
stoppen wird haben das tatsächlich
falsch eingeschätzt
bisher beeinflussen die Sanktionen das
Kriegsgeschehen weniger als erhofft ein
elftes Sanktionspaket soll bald kommen